for the first three years of world war
one the united states did very little
its position towards the great war was
one of annoyed neutrality and whilst it
was seen as a problem it was not seen as
america's problem yet despite the war
not directly affecting the us woodrow
wilson declared war on germany in april
of 1917 and joined the side of the
antant but given how easy it would have
been for the us to sit it out this
raises an obvious question why did the
united states join world war one to
begin when the great war broke out in
europe the us's response was oh good
another one because to many american
politicians and the american public at
large europeans were always fighting
over something often over silly things
like royal titles tiny strips of land or
some irrelevant imperial holding
somewhere across the pacific and this
conflict was seen as no different which
meant that many americans weren't
interested in getting involved this
worked well for america and importantly
president wilson who was much more
concerned with getting re-elected in
late 1916. to do this he needed the
support of the german-american and
irish-american populations who supported
the central powers and he also needed
the protestants living across the
eastern seaboard which supported the
anton and to win their votes he promised
that the u.s would never enter the war
but he also talked about how uncle
germany was being at that point but as
you'll know six months after he won
re-election toward the us went so why
well to start public opinion has slowly
shifted from who cares to not germany
over the past year this was mostly down
to germany's long-term goals largely
being will dominate europe and also
because of germany resuming unrestricted
submarine warfare which could target
american vessels and also the zimmermann
telegram in which the german empire
asked mexico to invade the united states
which was something not well received by
the american public now history buffs
amongst you will know that the american
public wanting something does not mean
that the american government is going to
do it and one of the most pressing
reasons for wilson to go to war was
money american business was making quite
a lot of money from the war since
exports to britain france and italy had
increased massively which is one of the
reasons that unrestricted submarine
warfare angered the us government so
much less exports meant less taxes and
governments like taxes another monetary
reason was loans the us government had
lent the untaunt nations a lot of money
a lot and conquered defeated nations
aren't exactly able to pay that money
back which helped took the american
leadership into going to war and another
reason was that the american government
simply didn't know what would happen if
germany won britain was europe's
greatest power at that point and whilst
the americans didn't exactly love them
they understood them whereas germany was
the offspring of prussia and to them was
an ambitious militaristic state which if
victorious would inevitably clash with
the u.s somewhere and so to wilson's
government dealing with germany now
would rid the world of an autocratic
threat in the future and this view of
america siding with the right nations
was an extremely important one since
most americans were equally as disgusted
by the autocratic russian empire as they
were by the german one well good news
because they just dropped out to try
their hands at the whole civil war thing
and with russia gone this meant that for
americans the war now had a right side
and a wrong side and there wasn't much
time for america to join if the right
side was going to win and with public
pressure growing wilson went to congress
to ask that it make a declaration of war
against germany and this declaration was
voted for overwhelmingly thereby
bringing the united states into world
war one and honestly ruining the
kaiser's day
i hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching with a special
thanks to my patrons james bissonette mr
wolfe kelly money maker skye chappelle
jerry landon jordan longley adam stalter
corso wolf gareth turner marvin castell
why in hockey captain cydog spencer
lightfoot boogerly wiggly matthew
shipley maggie paxkowski aaron the white
robert wetzel marcus asner anthony
beckett alex schwinn the muk whopper
gustav swan copper tone spinning three
plates moe winston k wood charles the
first ben evanson and scottish trekkie